et les jamaïque à sauver les oiseaux à y
aller tous les ans que je chante dans le
ghetto lafarge chômage ou west gate ou
araignées et ça soulage le reggae c'est
toujours le meilleur ambassadeur
d'ailleurs à kingston le seul endroit
qui soit considéré comme il sait le
musée la liste à venir
seize ans après sa mort le prophète a
toujours des millions de fans je pensais
en préparation
journaliste musicien il adore le marais
des années rebelles une passion qui l'a
conduit à équiper tous que les oilers
enregistré entre 76 et 72 à l'époque de
la vache enragée
c'est les années du ghetto c'est les
années de bob marley quand il n'était
pas connu c'est à dire qu'ils vivaient
dans les bidonvilles de kingston quand
il pouvait vraiment très difficilement
et évidemment c'est comme outil de la
soirée c'était un poème jamaïque et côte
est des états unis à la fin des années
60 ce qui parce qu'elle est black
panthers et immoral c'était viennent
vendre
bon voilà la lutte pour les droits
civiques american et le jamaïcain
s'identifier complètement has après donc
soit vous partez ce dépôt place
ressusciter le marley des années noires
ne fut pas chose aisée il a fallu
débrouiller les histoires de droits
retrouver l'époque original ou à défaut
les 45 tours dépens et puis aussi
restauré parce que les galettes de
vinyles des années 60 sa gratte un peu
le résultat c'est 11 album au son très
jamaïcain
aïe
un son qui donne envie de danser un
retour aux sources du reggae
secrètes nous et qui favorise pour la
poule et à l'instar du bois devant joie
elle regus et la nourriture de l'âme
à propos des lycées la piposa rideau
is to black et jay deux anges noirs mois
sont les anges gardiennes et fais le
tanto peut-être qu'un plan les anges
razer visite les éditeurs et dites nous
on est pour aller tout va bien salut
beau